[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
carson palmer his appearance brought to
you by the cbd trusted by professional
athletes level select cbd make sure you
use the promo code dp30 30 off your
entire order today
not available in idaho iowa and south
dakota go to
levelselectcbd.com as we say good
morning as we always do on monday to
carson palmer former nfl quarterback
heisman trophy winner i was curious
if i go back to your days at usc when
you knew you were going to be the number
one overall pick but let's say you were
playing in the peach bowl
not a playoff game
would would carson palmer of today
play in a game like that
i would have um back then it just wasn't
heard of i mean really nobody had really
really done it until christian mccaffrey
did it at stanford and i don't remember
what bold game it was but it wasn't the
orange bowl
and i remember at the time the sun bowl
yeah um i remember at the time thinking
well he should have a pretty good idea
on what's right knowing his dad ted
mccaffrey and played in the league for a
long time so he's probably got some
really good guidance on this
uh and being a running back and the hits
they take and the pounding that they
take and the possibility of injury is
probably greater than a quarterback but
it just wasn't heard of until christian
mccaffrey did it and now guys are doing
it weekend and week out as we get to
bowl season
and you just don't know who's available
but back then when i was playing it was
just a chance to play one more game at
the end of the day in college football
you only get like 12 opportunities to
put put film out there to get drafted so
you know
my mindset back then and a majority of
all college football players mindset was
you need a game film you need
opportunities and chances to shine and
show what you can do for nfl teams to be
able to draft you so it was just one
more opportunity to go out and perform
and hop and possibly get drafted higher
yeah but you knew you were going to be a
heisman trophy candidate or you were
going to win the heisman you're going to
be a top five pick
do you play in a game
if you had that season at usc would you
be playing in a meaningless bowl game
at a non-playoff game now would you be
like can he pick it or would you be like
matt corral
i i would play i mean i i i played in
the senior bowl which which wasn't
really for a
a championship or really anything you
know for your college career um but the
senior bowl came along and i got invited
and i wanted to go and play and compete
against those guys i do understand it i
mean at this
you know i understand part of it guys
don't want to get hurt guys don't want
to hurt their their draft stock but now
guys can also actually make money in
college and and put some money in the
bank um so you've had an opportunity to
earn some money and and put some money
away for you know for the rest of your
life
now you're hearing about you know bryce
at alabama you know has already made a
million bucks in college so you know
when you weigh in the fact that back in
the day you couldn't make any money
and guys didn't miss the opportunity to
play in bowl games and now guys can make
money and guys are dropping out of bowl
games left and right because they're
worried about their future earnings so
it's you know the correlation there
doesn't make sense i i think you play
and if if you really love playing the
game and you love the opportunity to
compete with your guys the guys you came
in with your you know your
your freshman class and all that there's
so many little added things that go into
it that you know i i have a tough time
watching guys not play
aaron rodgers was asked about playing
against the lions they've wrapped up the
number one seed in the nfc and of course
he's been battling the toe injury
and
i was wondering does he even play in
this game um your thoughts on rogers
playing or not playing in a meaningless
game against the lions
i think the most valuable player trophy
means a lot more to aaron than than a
lot of people realize and i think he's
still got a chance to win the mvp he's
possibly the front runner if not in the
top three he could use three or four
more touchdown passes another 400 yards
another you know another statistically
dominant performance in order to be in
in you know in the running at the end of
the year for the mvp so i see him
playing and on top of that too when
we're talking about a little a little
bone in your foot that's broken
that's not gonna help that in another
week doesn't automatically fix that or
change that if it was a ligament um
issue or some damage to a muscle maybe a
hamstring pull or a quad pull something
like that a week can be
um you know
an immense amount of of healing time but
when you're talking about a broken a
broken pinky toe or a broken foot
it's just not enough to to miss an
entire an entire week's work and another
chance to go out and statistically have
a great day you're the first person to
answer it i think correctly and that is
that m that mvp for aaron rodgers this
year is an fu to a lot of people and i
think that
that might be at the crux of this that
he can say to the packers hey
my foot my toe it's not going to get any
better hopefully it doesn't get any
worse but we're a number one seed i
don't want to be not playing for two
weeks because if you don't play against
lines you don't play in that first week
of the playoffs i want to be ready to go
and at the crux of this is probably and
it'd be nice to go back-to-back mvps
no doubt i mean he hasn't talked about
it he can't talk about it
anybody that's played and been in his
position before you know that that is
extremely important that's another just
another little piece of leverage as he
moves into this offseason we don't know
which way he's going it's just another
little bit of leverage and leverages
everything in this game should baker
mayfield play against the steelers
tonight
absolutely 100 percent um he baker's got
to prove himself and unfortunately he
hasn't done enough to prove himself as
being the future in the franchise the
you know long term six seven eight year
contract guy and but he's injured though
carson and if he hasn't proven to you
yet
i don't know if playing tonight against
the steelers does anything
true it you know he can go out and and
you know operate at 60 or 70 percent and
60 or 70 percent for baker you know
isn't enough to beat a rivalry team and
the pittsburgh steelers on the road so
no doubt but nolan baker he's got that
mentality he's not going to let anybody
you know take his spot he doesn't want
you know he doesn't want to have the
opportunity to stay on the sideline
watch somebody else play his position
he's very competitive he's ultra ultra
competitive so i just i think he plays
and there's no doubt about it
yeah i wonder about it because he hasn't
played well
and
you're playing against steelers it'll be
big i know it's a rivalry game but it's
a game that doesn't really mean anything
i i don't know it feels like he could do
more harm than good uh speaking of which
antonio brown
um
do you have any idea who he is
yeah he's uh a constant distraction
i mean now now
dan we talked every week and i talk all
the time about just these distractions
this this issue that this team has to
answer questions mike evans tom brady
fernette all these guys they're going to
be talking about antonio brown all week
bruce erin's going to go into every he's
got three pressers this week every press
conference he's going to go into he's
got to talk about antonio brown and got
it it's it's just another distraction
unfortunately i think we've seen the
last antonio brown i'd be shocked if
somebody else gave him another
opportunity um but really really
disappointed i mean he was such a great
player he blew so many opportunities and
and really got in his own way he
consistently got in his own way in
pittsburgh and we saw what happened
there he got in his own way in oakland
las vegas we saw what happened there he
now got in his own way in tampa and the
third time's the charm i think we've
seen the end of one of the most talented
uh athletically given
uh receivers that i've had the
opportunity to watch with with my eyes
on a field and it's just unfortunate
we're talking to carson palmer former
nfl quarterback i i go back to that
cheap shot by montez berfit and i i
don't know if
one hit changes you but it felt like and
and i could be way off a base here but
it felt like that he he became something
different then or something happened to
him and maybe he was a diva all the time
but i i don't know just
i still go back to that and i thought
about that yesterday as he's leaving the
field i'm i go back to that shot he took
from vontez berfit
i disagree i i don't think it's one hit
i don't think it's one play i think it's
a combination of
fame
money
power um you know he he got a taste that
he was an undrafted guy or a late round
draft pick from a school that a lot of
people you know didn't know how to
football team he started off on the
practice squad he worked his way up he
went from no fame to one of the most
famous players in the nfl in those
couple of years there in pittsburgh and
some guys it's just too much to handle
some guys can't deal with it
unfortunately the more fame the more the
more respect the more power he's gotten
to be able to show up and not want to
put pleats on or whatever that issue was
in las vegas with his cleats and his
burnt feet
you know once you get a taste of that
fame and that power
um you know unfortunately some guys
can't handle it it just looks like he
couldn't handle it because the situation
was so good with john gruden there
playing for the raiders and derek carr
and that system would have been so good
not that the system wasn't so good for
him with ben roethlisberger in
pittsburgh i mean another great
situation
maybe he saw the writing on the wall
with ben you know getting older and
going downhill but there he was in
playing for the raiders in a great
situation
then new england and then tampa i mean
the the situations and the quarterbacks
he's had a chance to play with
not everybody gets that opportunity and
not very many guys would would
absolutely ruin those opportunities and
we've seen him consistently ruin every
opportunity he's gotten
matthew stafford fascinates me and
worries me all in the same game
and not necessarily in that order carson
what concerns do you have if any
well just like you said the
inconsistencies i mean
some of the balls he throws there's only
two or three other guys in the league
can actually throw that ball and then
some of the balls he he throws there's a
whole bunch of guys across the country
that could throw those and make that
decision
um you know it's at some point you know
we're starting to get into past that
point of where it's a new team it's a
new offense it's a new system they're
new receivers
he's had plenty of time to consistently
work with those guys and develop rapport
and trust and respect with those guys
unfortunately there's times he just
doesn't look on the same page where he's
expecting a guy to be a little higher in
a route or a little flatter in a route
and he's off one way or the other so
we're getting to that point where it is
starting to be concerning because
they've had plenty of time to work and
and develop that relationship and that
rapport
unfortunately we're getting that time
where one of those decisions one of
those errant throws can cause you to go
home and not no longer play in the
playoffs so it's absolutely concerning
um they have enough talent they have
enough
just raw athletes on both sides of the
ball to overcome one of those in the
playoffs but when you start talking
about one or two of those decisions in
the play in the playoffs those can bite
you in the butt how do you utilize
cooper cup
because he's not your prototypical
number one wide receiver wide guy speed
guy
so as a quarterback how do you i know
they've done a pretty good job because
he's got you know 1800 yards this year
but what what is it that you know how do
you utilize somebody who doesn't
necessarily beat you with great speed
just get the ball in his hands get get
the ball in his hands give him as many
chances he had a play he was he had a
six or seven yard gain on third down and
it looked like he was going to step out
of bounds and and somehow someway he
made
a cut back in bounds and got another 15
or 20 yards out of a play where you're
just going there's nothing left in this
play
except for a guy like cooper cup who can
just like a magician find a way to to
almost step out of bounds but cut back
against the grain and make three guys
miss
you don't got it it's not about running
4-2 it's not about a inch vertical jump
it's about when the ball is in your
hands what do you do with it and he
consistently from from week one of his
rookie year until right now he's
consistently made plays he's
consistently created separation to get
open and then his yak and and yards
after the first touch i mean he's
breaking tackles he's spin moving he's
cutting against the grain uh he may not
be the prototypical 4-2 42-inch vertical
guy but he's a number one
you know he's a number one threat from a
receiver position in just about every
offense across the league everybody
would take him
great stuff great to talk to you again
carson and uh we'll talk to you next
week happy new year to you and the
family
thanks dan happy new year that's carson
palmer his weekly appearance during the
nfl season brought to you by our partner
level select cbd looking for next level
relief visit levelselectcbd.com